mindfulness isn't sort of an indulgent
rest you know it's not like deep
relaxation it's it's almost gym for the
mind so you're building that mental
muscle to be able to notice where your
mind is notice if it's helpful for you
or not and then bring it back to now and
I think what people are referring to is
worry right so it's that kind of I'm
thinking about things way too much I'm
going around and round in circle it's
almost like that kind of thought washing
machine isn't it where you're just
churning it over and over most things
that are sort of meaningful or feel like
achievements involve discomfort on the
way so if you're not willing to make
yourself feel vulnerable and
uncomfortable you kind of close a lot of
doors to yourself I
think